if you want to drink brewery fresh beer
in your own home your options are pretty
limited you've either got to get a whole
keg or buy a half gallon growler fresh
from the tap
both are inconvenient this is where hops
ease home tap makes things easier for
beer lovers the home tab is small enough
to fit on a countertop in your kitchen
or in the break room at work
it looks like a MacPro turned sideways
the beer comes in special two-liter
bottles they're supplied by local micro
breweries who have partnered with hopsie
it works like this
you insert the big bottle run the
built-in hose to the devices tap handle
then close and lock the door the beer is
kept cold inside the machine when it's
time to pour the home tap pushes air
into the plastic bottle this puts
pressure on the bag inside squeezing the
beer out through the tap and into your
glass air never touches the beer so the
suds stay fresh for up to two weeks
after you buy a home tap hopsie delivers
beer of your choosing to your door as
often as you'd like it's not available
outside of select areas and your beer
choices are limited but come on you love
beer so surely you can find something on
the menu to quench your thirst